Speaker 1: Last week, the January 6th House
committee investigating the Trump riots voted
to subpoena the failed former president himself.
Is he going to show up? Almost certainly not. Are
the best legal assessments. Trump's reaction was
to send a delusional 14 page letter, including
pictures of the crowd on January 6th. Why on
earth would you want to point fingers at that?
Donald Trump was investigated and subpoenaed.
Everything's legal. Everything's kosher. Every eye
is crossed and t dotted to quote sean hannity and
trump flipped out peacefully and patriotically. He
calls this letter and he writes to the chairman
of the January six committee, Bennie Thompson.
The same goes sorry, the presidential election
of 2020 was rigged and stolen. The same group of
radical left Democrats who utilize their capital
m majority position in Congress to create the
fiction of Russia. Russia, Russia. Impeachment
hoax number one. Impeachment hoax number two,
the $48 million Mueller report which ended
in no collusion. Ukraine. Ukraine, Ukraine.
The atrocious and illegally capital s spying on my
capital C campaign and so much more are the people
who created this committee of highly partizan
political capital h hacks and capital t thugs
whose sole function is to destroy the lives
of many hardworking American patriots whose
records in life have been unblemished
until this point of attempted ruination.
Folks. That's one sentence and I'm already out
of breath. This goes on and on and on and it is
delusional and it blames Antifa and it blames
Black Lives Matter and it talks about Trump
having Time magazine covers and stories, and
it's absolutely bonkers and I encourage you to
read all of it. It includes such lines as Since
1888, no incumbent president has gained votes and
lost reelection. Okay. That doesn't really tell us
anything. Trump says we swept all four bellwether
states Iowa, Florida, Ohio and North Carolina,
and they have correctly predicted election
winners since 1896. Trump using a lot of what we
don't actually call evidence that he won. It's
not evidence that he won. And then he even goes
on later in this completely delusional letter.
And by the way, it's riddled with lies, like he
tried to get the National Guard out on January
six. There's no evidence of that. None whatsoever.
He goes on to talk about he presents evidence from
Wisconsin, which we will get to. Trump includes
an appendix in the letter, which has an image of
Washington, D.C., I guess, on January 6th. I don't
know why you would call attention to that, because
your followers rioted and committed hundreds of
crimes. Many pictures. And then he starts talking
about Arizona and Maricopa County, including lots
of debunked claims that there were mismatched
signatures and that there was fraud. And auditors
found this, that and the other thing. He also
cites Dr. Shiva, who's a completely conspiratorial
nutjob. It's completely bonkers. And when you
actually take each of these claims and investigate
them, you say, okay, well, let's look at Arizona,
what actually happened in Arizona. You look at
Arizona and you find that almost every single
one of these claims, every claim, is either an
outright lie or an exaggeration that the numbers
were looked at. The what are called overvotes
were actually less significant in 2020 than in
prior elections. You look at every single one of
the lawsuits that was brought in Arizona, and you
find that some were voluntarily dismissed. For
example, the Aguilera von tests lawsuit known as
the original Sharpie lawsuit. It was voluntarily
dismissed. The second suit brought by Aguilera
alleging, oh, my vote wasn't counted. I want to
cast a new ballot. It was dismissed with prejudice
on the merits. It was not an issue of standing
as many people like Mike Pillow like to claim.
You just look through all the lawsuits and you see
every single one of these claims Trump makes was
either so baseless that it didn't go anywhere or
it was evaluated by a court and it was dismissed
with prejudice. In many of these cases, it is
a delusional letter. He goes on to talk about
Georgia. We've looked at Georgia extensively.
These claims are not accurate. Just to pick one
random one of these things, Trump writes at least
10,300 illegally cast votes in Georgia. Maybe
35,000 are from individuals who voted in the
wrong county more than necessary to tip the 2020
results. Remember some of the people that voted
in the wrong county? What happened is they moved,
they moved. They were registered in two places
as is common. As long as you only vote in one
place and you are legally registered there, you're
fine. Also, look at this margin of error somewhere
between ten and 35,000 such votes. It's all lies
and you can page through it. It goes on eventually
to talk about Michigan. We've talked about
Michigan and honestly, Pennsylvania has maybe
looked at and been looked at more closely than
any other state, Wisconsin. And this is really
a gish gallop of outrageous proportions. Trump So
triggered by the subpoena that he sends a 14 page
letter riddled with lies and pictures in response.
Now, will Trump actually respond to the subpoena
and show up to testify before the January 6th
committee? Almost certainly not. We're linking to
two articles, one from NPR called. So Donald Trump
has been subpoenaed. Here is what comes next.
The other article from the Lawfare blog, Trump
Responds to January six Committee Subpoena. Almost
certainly Trump will not be showing up to testify.
And then the question becomes what happens next?
These articles tell you, we'll link to them. We'll
talk about them tomorrow. In the meantime, you can
find me on Twitter at David Pakman. The David
Pakman Show continues to be a viewer, listener
and community funded program. I would love for
you to sign up on my web site, join Pacman dot
com where you can get access to the daily bonus
show as well as commercial free audio and video
streams of the show. We're down to the end, folks,
and you can use the coupon code, big voting 22 to
get yourself a discount. It's cheap. It's quick.
The money goes directly into our operation and
you get some great perks. You can sign up at
join Packman dot com coupon code big voting 22.